thanks so much for being with us what is
foreign team like for you right now what
is life like for you right now
it's really present and I say this
because I really have started to learn
the art of being mindful which is like
being aware of what our conversation is
like right now being aware of the
temperature in the room being aware of
my food instead of just scarfing it down
and driving at the same time or whatever
it is that we usually do so right now I
just notice I have no other reason but
to be super present in all my
conversations in the chore that I'm
doing the organizing even writing a
letter like you're just all up there and
I love it so I tend to look at the
bright side of things so that has been
super rewarding for me and my
relationships around me I mean my text
messages and my phone calls have never
been this thoughtful or even just such
playful you know usually you coffee but
you're like okay are you gonna send this
in when is this due um I don't know give
me my money or whatever it may be this
time is about like hey how are you wait
I haven't talked to your grandfather but
your grandfather on the line let me
FaceTime you guys you know have you guys
you know gone back in your old book of
old high-school yearbook pictures like
have you taken a walk down that memory
lane what new dance did you come up with
did you download tick-tock let me see
what we can do with your mom like it's
it's just it's heartwarming
so I even though it's a tough time yeah
every day is a reward to treat it like
your very favorite day off which is
amazing it sounds like you're
flourishing during this time like you're
reconnecting with people you do FaceTime
with people more and I think what you're
saying about being present is so
important who are you with right now I
mean your mom's there I'm guessing
Gigi's there like the situation Farrah
sure so my mom is staying here at my
house on her own we well we have family
that you know visits her but we're all
really quarantine II her because I am
doing this for my mom I'm doing it for
every elder out there and kept them from
themselves
so mom eyes here Jeezy and I are staying
at his place and we have her come over
for movies we like literally come over
pick her up spray her
with alcohol I literally by the way I
should tell people um I do this on the
norm this is how I actually stand the
taste my house with bugs like gnats or
fruit flies or flies if you can't get
them with the fly swatter we have a 99%
isopropyl
oh so fulfilled I don't know how to
pronounce but we have it filled with
alcohol and you just spray it see
sanitize where the bug lands but you
also cleanse or clean our rug but now
we've been like you know cover your eyes
and Mel but we douse each other in it if
you've been outside in a public place
all your clothes I don't care it's kind
of funny we're like shed everything take
everything off in your chonies get to
the bathroom and take a bath and then
come back out you know so it's really
important at this time to keep your
house completely sanitized like ya know
taking chances on that like I don't even
don't ever come in from outside wearing
your pants and then sit on the couch
like you know the airborne we also know
that its water particles it's a lot so
so we want to just you know maintain
cleanliness how is your mom doing I know
that you guys are close I always see her
on your Instagram page like is she it's
okay oh my how are you doing mom am i
okay to survive hi how are you doing I'm
fine thanks I love you have beautiful
long hair I mean it's I got a lot of
roots right now going always with me cuz
you've got nothing else to do you guys
just think that talking about I heard
you're cooking a little bit though I do
I do but today I had relaxed because
yesterday I cook so much so she brought
over she spent maybe six hours and
guiliani vegetables and put them
together in a seafood mix and then yeah
meet Nick Ryder over to our house all in
saran wrap wrapped up we lay it out in a
row and you guys we made egg rolls
assembly line style GZ made like mid
like I don't know 30 and it was amazing
which whose egg rolls are better mom I
didn't I think yeah yeah and Daniel
Daniel's my brother what is the words
one Wow yeah Wow throw in genie under
the bus here how do you feel
it's true it's true better come first
I was I was busy Instagram story so I
did not pay attention to those egg rolls
and I could care less because I would
rather eat everybody else mega burrito
that is so funny
for good goodbye yeah so my egg rolls
looks like burritos but but I'll be
posting that video soon it's it's really
cute it's just everybody we're making
foods that you can store so whether it's
egg rolls or beef stew my mom made a
whole thing of these two and then froze
the rest of it so that when you're ready
to eat you just you know throw it into a
saucepan and let it stew down egg rolls
are great for frying and then they can
hold up to a week in your refrigerator
or you can freeze them as well and then
just put them in the toaster oven and
heat them up so it's all about making
foods that feel homey feel good so that
you're taking care of yourself and you
don't come out of this feeling even more
lethargic or you know having weight gain
or even more depression depression is
number one for me I want to keep this
mind pure in hell and happy I mean
mental health is everything right now
and it sounds like for you guys you
there is a sense of like camaraderie in
a way right it sounds like you guys are
cooking together do you feel like this
is bringing your family closer together
and also you and jay-z closer together
in a way that's so funny we looked at
each other you know um by this time of
the quarantine you know we were like yo
we make it do this we are gangster no
I'm just kidding
no we're amazing um uh yes like I said
so I'm a super introvert meaning I love
quality conversations I love intimacy I
love you know thoughtful presence with
one another so this is a dream for me
and it allows me to focus and think
about ways that we can support people
who need it out there and so we've been
brainstorming ways to help the community
any of the elders who can't get their
groceries we're looking for ways to help
anybody just do a grocery store pickup I
mean we're able and when we can drive in
just dropping it off the doorstep so
keeps everybody safe we're also in talks
with Michael Costello to help him create
more masks
working with Christian Siriano and
they're trying to get to a place where
they can make a bulk amount of mass to
help out these hospitals so again I
don't know if we'd think this clearly
when you don't when you don't have this
you know this this beautiful quality
time with each other to say hey like
what can we do most of the time if you
know this wasn't happening we'd be
talked about like what out for dinner or
what wear day was like or already
worrying about her schedule the next day
and so this is a really special time for
couple you'll either you know you'll
learn a lot after you get out and I
learned that he's such a an inspiring
person to be around and fun so I think
inspiration and humor are the two
quality ingredients you should have in
your vibe right now yeah I love that
that's a great answer um you mentioned
Christian Siriano making those masks I
didn't know that Michael was also doing
that yeah so he he's in touch with
Christian or kind of walk me through how
that's gonna happen so Michael Costello
got in touch with Christian to help out
on his end because he obviously has an
entire team of seamstresses that can put
this together actually at this very
moment the one block that is keeping him
from being able to bust out 2,500 masks
a day with his team is an approval from
our council to allow him to have the
actual fabrics for the mask to start
making them so I'm calling a few council
people that I know I'm also we were also
writing a letter to mayor Garcetti and
we're trying to get this resolved so if
you guys stay tuned to my Instagram at
the Jeannie Mai or follow Atma Michael
Costello we'll have a way that everybody
can jump in and help us before we
involve everybody we want to try to get
this huh I think it's done ourselves
because those masks can be done daily
why is it so hard to get that fabric is
it it's there's there's things that come
along with it besides just the fabric
itself it's actually making sure that
the fabric is issued to a department or
a warehouse which he does have access to
a warehouse on a station this is so cool
listen how the community can is going up
honest Asia who is your Alice queen of
rouse has offered her entire warehouse
which is huge for them to be able to
safely make the masks so they're
figuring it out and the reason why the
fabric has to be released after it's
it's understood where they're going to
be made so that we don't make a problem
worse by making this mask what you may
have yeah how is work being affected for
you right now yeah so um as a host of
the real right all the ladies we are on
hiatus so it's not affecting so much
right now we coincidentally hit the same
time as a hiatus but it's so important
to have social media to keep in touch
with our fans I I love that our show is
meant to educate and entertain educate
and also just enlighten people wear
silly we're fun we're also passionate
and so the show going on every day on
Fox helps for people to just take their
mind off things I also love just making
content so I have a youtube channel
called hello honey and I have a podcast
- that's called listen honey and both
offer insightful conversations fun
things that go on with me and Mama my
this week actually mama my shows us her
home remedies where she takes us through
her kitchen and all the stuff that she
puts on her face we make a very
interesting discovery with aloe so I
think right now what's important is to
not sit there and just lament about the
problems to come don't get so bogged up
about the negativity that's out sides
because right now if you're staying
still great that's it if you're slowing
your movement or at least staying home
and you are already a solution to the
problem that's the number one thing that
you should already feel good about so
that we're getting to that place of of
healing and cleansing the air with this
virus the second thing to keep in mind
is to watch things that make you laugh
happy people produce better results like
when you're happy you actually have more
insightful conversations with people you
look at life differently even your view
out the window becomes a lot brighter so
making sure that you stay positive
whatever that might be for some it might
be organizing
he'll love that junk drawer right for
others it might be um um you know
actually cooking something that you
haven't tried for a long time a recipe
we were talking about crock pot recipes
earlier and I'm dragging out my crock
pot that's been sitting in the shelf for
such a long time because I love you know
just putting you know match things in
like potatoes and sauces and curries and
then seeing like what comes out like its
you know so these are times to get to
know yourself and to be able to use
these skills you have or Google if you
don't have them and I do want to share
this one thing because I was talking to
my friends and you know when you mention
work though obviously I'm I'm blessed
for now you know even though obviously
we don't even know if the real can come
back right because that's what I was
gonna ask you you know can shoot again
we don't have a live audience well you
know why should we be able to and
everything's quarantine like that
wouldn't be safe right so what I wanted
to tell people though is recently on my
Instagram I talked about a list of
things you should do to get your
financing in order so that you feel more
organized about what's being spent it's
things like checking your credit card
bill if you have any subscriptions that
are going on cancel them immediately
calling your credit card company cuz a
lot of credit card companies are waiving
the interest fees to relax you a bit for
this next coming month also auto loan
companies or car payments like again if
you call these lenders they're all
they're able to make this work out for
you so if you go to my Instagram I have
a phone number their text me and I can
send you the exact list so that you can
do that and then it just like releases
the pressure it allows you to not be so
worried yeah that's so helpful um just
to go back to the real for a second so
is there a timeline of what you guys are
thinking that you could go back to work
or is it a day-by-day thing like it
could be months it could it could be
months yeah yeah so we're due to come
back mid-april
but at this point nobody's doing
anything until we know that America is
safe until we know that America's healed
so I think we're all on the same page to
make the best decision as we hunker down
so
that's our focus for right now as as a
host of that show as pretty much like an
anchor of Pat show how do you feel about
all these broadcasters who are you know
broadcasting from home right now or
having to go into the studio we see
these reporters on CNN like did that
what do you make of that well I'm
recording my podcast listen honey from
home and all my content is also from
home so I don't mind it I also have to
say it's a really fun time in social
media right now I am in love with the
families that are getting to death
together shooting videos I'm in love
with these stories Kevin Hart is giving
you confessions yeah people are
mimicking outdoor activities like clubs
in their house you know turning on the
disco light and you know so there's
there's so many cool things that are
going on and we're connecting like the
number one thing I love about the
American spirit is that we won't die
like we ourselves our love to
communicate our passion to be able to do
things that we love that's never gonna
die so I think right now for anybody out
there
social media is kind of like a
therapeutic diary social media unit and
we're not doing it for likes but we're
not doing it for approval we're not
doing it to bully each other at God but
what we're doing right now is kind of
giving a day-by-day quarantined diary to
be like today green bean like whatever
it might be but it's funny it actually
allows you you know when they always ask
you sometimes in questions like what's
what something weird you do that nobody
knows about or you know like you know
what's something people don't know about
you these questions are being seen
completely through social media from
yeah through everybody every celebrity
I'm learning something I wouldn't
thought before and it's making us feel
like we're all in this together oh you
want Ellen like freaked out like laying
on her couch calling perct in like you
know mess like I love it I think it's
awesome yeah I do too um you are the
number one fashionista in my mind you
know all these tips so we do have a few
like beauty and fashion questions for
you if you don't mind what is maybe like
a a beauty route
team that takes a little bit longer than
now you're having time to do because
you're at my skin yeah my skin okay I'm
obsessed with skin if my skin looks good
I feel good
I could I could fluctuate in weight I
could you know not be in the gym for a
minute but with my skin feels patchy and
pimply and dry I just feel like I've
given up on myself so I have been taking
the time every day to give myself a
really good skin pampering so it might
be exfoliating with sugar and honey like
natural sugar and honey or you know
busting out some of the products that
you bought but you just blow the dust
off of because you haven't used in a
while it's also you know layering my
skin with serums using a hot towel to
steam my mom earlier made some rice and
she was like after she made the rice and
she dumped the rice out the pot still
had water and it was steamy and she just
sat there opening all her pores then
went to the bathroom and kind of
extracted a few blackheads what you have
to do very carefully do you really have
questions about that texted me about she
treats that better and then when she was
done like her face looks so refreshed
she had a little bit of a rose hip oil
on it it was beautiful but when your
skin feels good you're gonna come out of
this banging guys make sure you're
taking care of your skin take your body
do at home workouts I do one called what
the waste and you know Instagram and you
have trainer on guys we're not losing
all of this you cannot do not let
yourself go down with the quarantine
that's not what's happening yeah it's
time to actually work more on yourself
if you think this is that new time that
we're always asking about you know and
moms out there to make sure that you're
talking with your kids to do the same so
that they're occupied taking care of
themselves so that you can get that you
time for you yeah absolutely
a lot of girls out there are struggling
right now if they have eyelash
extensions if they've dyed their hair
yeah it's gonna be a while girls that
need a little I know if you want to see
my nails right now oh God and I love you
know what I love too I've been loving
watching Instagram and seeing like all
the men a little furrier like
thank you yes what is your advice or
your tip to women out there who can't
maintain the regular mate throw it just
who cares we all get to let it go the
things I think should matter okay the
things that I think should matter is
your skin and your health so make sure
you're not just sitting there eating
frito-lay all the day although it sounds
good but not you're not just eat it
you're going out to the grocery store
like one time to get everything you need
without boarding and make yourself fresh
smoothies freezing soups and stews
making chopped vegetables and putting
them in airtight containers so that you
can just pull them out make a slaw or a
salad and then just taking care of your
skin you know you don't necessarily on
right now and that's about it
oh and I have lashes on but I also have
I do lashings I don't do like extension
women's so for all y'all where it's
growing out yay Congrats now you're free
as a bird haha and now you can wear
strips or not sometimes I wear strips
sometimes they don't but it is important
to take care of yourself because when
you don't when you kind of let yourself
go there's that there's a take care of
yourself and don't care about nail fill
and roots and stuff but then there's
also uh letting yourself go when you're
not taking care of yourself right you
don't want to get to that place because
then you'll see yourself and it'll make
you upset or find ways to pick on
yourself or you won't even be motivated
to get out of the house and walk right
and do within distance from each other
so just make sure that you still look
ready for the day so that you are ahead
of the day not letting the day get ahead
of you yeah we don't want to be in art I
mean I want to be my sweats all day but
maybe not all day every day right right
not every day and that's okay like I'm
wearing you know um shirt in a legging
you know what I mean it's like it's fine
but this was also a plain t-shirt I got
for my birthday and then I had time so i
YouTubed
how to cut t-shirts and you made this
and I made this whole yeah you just
slice it here and then measure out your
neckline here and cut a little hole so
it just had a little bit more of an
industry shape yeah it looks awesome
you know yeah you know I don't love
wearing big oversized shirts unless it's
tucked in or something but I'm not
tucking in anything and nobody's wearing
jeans at home so yeah no wonder Angie
thanks to youtube yeah that is the truth
any events I mean we're hearing about
Coachella stagecoach like everything
being canceled did you have tickets to
anything upcoming that you are looking
forward to to going to and rocking out
that fashion that we know you for you
know last night I was very lucky to
attend DJ nicest virtual DJing session
what Michelle Obama was in there Rihanna
has been in there BOM I loved it when I
was posting an Instagram and somebody
hit me up like yo girl you need to be a
DJ nicest place I was like what were
jumped over there and I was so I was so
excited he was playing like Jurassic 5
and so many dope old-school miss mixes
disco it was so sick and and it was so
comforting to see everybody be able to
come together and have vibes you know
just like bringing energy that's so cool
and for him to do that that was
brilliant so I am excited for artists to
get creative with different ways that
they can entertain us you know whether
it's making content from home
influencers or pulling things out of our
hat now for content at home and then I
think it would be really cool of artists
collab and maybe did like some
performances you know maybe somehow on
with their own Coachella in a way well
on the house party or being able to do
it through a FaceTime and group video
calls on whatsapp there's so many
different ways to do it so I think this
is a really special time for people to
get creative and to break away from the
norms that we are so used to and enjoy
that we're all in this together do you
feel like you've been more creative
these past couple of weeks that's funny
right when you said that I'm looking at
this okay so I'm looking at this list of
papers that that I have so okay there's
this thing I do in my house it's like
genies bowl of questions right and I'll
randomly come up with different
questions I'll write them on a list like
this and then I'll I'll cut them up and
I'll basically fold these each and put
them in a bowl
these questions I'll have around and
I'll just randomly stick a bowl in my
mom's face and be like answer one which
one you want me to read now why I'd have
to do now and I'm like we're trying to
send call any time with each other so um
so yeah I love doing this and I I've
been doing it with my fans so um I've
actually will post an Instagram video
where I'm gonna ask this question and
everybody can text me their answer and
then from there I'm able to just
communicate and hear people's individual
stories like some of the questions are
um let's see
okay what do your friends hate most
about the way you drive how do you
answer that me okay so fun fact it's
only fun now that I've taken care of it
I cannot stay off the phone when I Drive
like I'll just like scroll or I'll have
to turn on YouTube or my eyes just need
to be fixated on the phone all the time
so I realized after my friends were
screaming at me that it was not yeah we
dangerous for myself and them so I
stopped driving so I only ever now I
know escape did you give up your car and
every yeah I gave it up I gave it to a
family member who took it very happily
by the way what beliefs do you have
about yourself that resulted from your
childhood
so anything that one told you that stuck
in your head you know what I mean like
that's that's a crazy memory lane I
would have to say from me so I grew up
really skinny and a lot of the kids made
fun of me calling me chicken legs and
for some reason I remembered because I
already had a picture of having weaker
chicken legs
it made me over proved that my legs were
super strong so whether it was like I
was a real a racer I always came down
first place I could run a mile in five
minutes
and even like now I lift heavy with you
know um yeah with all my leg lifts and
hip thrusts and all that come with like
having worked out my legs for some years
so even though my belief was that I had
chicken legs they're the strongest
chicken legs and the biz baby you've got
great legs they don't tell you anything
differently right okay we want to do a
little rapid fire with you before
okay um what's the first place that
you're going to first appointment that
you're gonna make as soon as you can
leave your hair leave Jeezy's house will
speak like it might be invited to say no
um I would say nails nails because I'm
pretty sure I mean this is that day 11
quarantine so I'm pretty sure you check
back with me in like a week or two and
we're gonna have a couple pieces missing
like this like what are you throwing
gang signs at me for what do you ran it
together um what's your go-to quarantine
snack food my go-to corn chew
let me grab it hold on okay gonna make
me hungry okay they sell these at Costco
which you know how that adventure is
gonna be but I'm pretty sure you can
also get these at Whole Foods but
they're called shrooms and they're
amazing they're dehydrated mushrooms BBQ
BBQ dude dude I'm trying to tell you
guys and you're basically eating a
carb-free snack for anybody who cares
you know for that reason but it's just
the first ingredient is mushrooms second
is canola oil it's so good and great for
you I'm gonna have to try those um okay
what are you binging right now and why
making of a murder oh my god I know it's
two years late I get it but like we said
this is the time where you get to do
things that you haven't been able to do
before so making over murder were on
three episodes out before the end do not
spoil it for me
he and I are like in this middle of this
war because he thinks Steven did it and
I think he's innocent so don't tell me
what happens but we have a vet that's
gonna take place for the loser
what who has to do what if you lose what
do you have to do yes the still decide
his I don't want to say I'm not gonna
say what it is because if I stay he's
he's gonna
come up with something better to butcher
me but I have a good dare that includes
that involves social media okay okay um
what's next on the binge list like what
else are you wanting to watch we watched
uh-oh what I want to watch what I want
to watch oh god I want it well it's not
just watch or not watch I want to listen
fully to the weekends latest album and
Childish Gambino's album that was just
dropped I'm obsessed with both of them
I heard the weekends albums fire reddit
is like blowing up about it so I want to
check out those I also want to I
actually want to create a vision board
our vision week for me or each week I
want to binge on all the things that I
need to get done so that I actually feel
accomplished by the end of the day so
Capricorn I know but that that he
actually Jay wants to join with me so
we're both gonna do that together which
is really cool um a cute couples
activity ah yeah we have a dryer room
board and it's it's popping already so
we just need to add things to it and he
has this junk drawer I've never seen so
many different things that can be fit
that can fit into a junk drawer like
guys glass bottles Chinese menus um if
there's lots of dollars there's like
just stuff where I'm like why this is
all in here and then I can't find one n
not one pen and it's like everything
everything you can think of if it works
so bad you can't pull it out anymore I'm
gonna say are you the one organizing it
or I'm your I'm gonna organize it but
I'm gonna I told him that I'm gonna tip
myself with the money that I find if he
doesn't help himself
and you better get some really good
brownie points for that that's right I
know I know is he making music right now
doing this he is he's always making
music
yes he's making music in fact if you
follow his gram Jeezy he is always he
actually just dropped a documentary that
he did with Sharla mean to God which is
really good he takes everybody home to
his hometown
in Florida so I'm sorry Florida Georgia
but he also just loves producing and
creating at all times you know he's got
a whole studio in this home so he's
always working on beats and different
things any new hobbies that you're
taking up or that you guys are taking up
together ooh you know what we worked at
we worked out for the first time
together like yes we works out at the
time I work out a ton and we both went
to the stairs the Culver City stairs
yeah it might not be it might be the
last time we go because we want to start
staying away from public places but it
was dope like we actually were doing
push-ups together we were doing jumps
together we're encouraging each other we
were sweating it was like you know I
mean we never would normally workout
together cuz we have our own gyms and
why would we but that really brought us
together and then we take walks
we take walks like a cute old couple he
presses the crosswalk sign and he walks
outside so that I'm not facing the
traffic like we take walks
it's really cute it almost makes life a
little simpler right which is nice yes
yeah I appreciate those little is you
know I mean normally when everything's
open and bustling you know you're
focused about what you're gonna have for
dinner what fancy restaurant you're
gonna go to how are you gonna wear your
makeup to this place who do you have to
feed you have to take a picture or
selfie in order to post it and share
with other people like there's so much
that goes into it now when you just hope
you decide to go and take walk you do
that oh you have five different
vegetables in your refrigerator what can
you make with this oh you both are
sitting together and haven't had an
earnest conversation about how life has
been like just simplicity it's beautiful
yeah I agree
um you are such a positive ray of
sunshine do you have advice or a message
to people out there who are watching
this or to your fans right now well
besides everything that we've talked
about I would say every person can help
everybody as we're seeing people come
out of the Woodworks whether they're
doing things like volunteering to shop
groceries for their elders if
you know healthy and enable to or if
they're able to just FaceTime friends
that need encouragement and remind them
not to panic and lift them out of it
or if you're like Michael Costello and
you've got a whole team that can sew and
possibly make masks for everybody look
at your resources and if you happen to
be somebody who is influential that has
a company or maybe a team look at what
you can do you know right now to just
encourage people or add some type of
help in any way and then if you're just
a if you're also if you're just a family
or any you know make us make some fun
content together when's the last time
you did a tick-tock with your kids do
you note that is did you download it
like get into this with your kids get
into one of these dance routines and and
get your kids to laugh at you it's so
fun to be able to like be on the same
level instead of watching two different
channels in two different instagrams
like get in there with your family you
know this is that time that even though
it's very difficult and our economy is
going to suffer and we're gonna go
through a rough patch if we are to get
there in United when we provide this we
will be even stronger than when we were
before so remember that we need every
individual person reaching places what a
lovely message you're just the best
thank you so much for doing this with us
and for taking the time
I can't wait to keep following along
with you and Hardison and your Instagram
so just keep doing what you're doing
because you're just beat you're such a
light right now thank you so much and
you guys care of each other outside
there too yeah
big hugs from afar absolutely virtual
hugs yes all right
bye guys
you